- 양자 정보와 계산의 이해에
오신 것을 환영해요.
제 이름은 John Watrous이고, IBM Quantum Education의
기술 디렉터예요.
이 시리즈의 목적은 양자 정보와 계산에 대한
탄탄한 이해를 제공하는 거예요, 그리고 그건 기술적인 세부 사항을 깊이 다루는 걸 의미해요
양자 정보의 기술적인 내용을 살펴보고 양자
컴퓨팅이 실제로 어떻게 작동하는지, 뭘 할 수 있고 뭘 할 수 없는지 알아볼 거예요.
이 시리즈의 개요 영상을
아직 안 보셨다면, 꼭 한번 확인해 보세요.
그 영상에서 이 시리즈에 권장되는 배경 지식이
어떤 건지, 그리고 다룰 주제들의 개요를 확인하실 수 있어요.
또한, Qiskit 교과서도 꼭 확인해 보세요.
이 영상 시리즈와 같은 내용을 글로 다루고 있어요,
그리고 여러분이 더 잘 이해할 수 있도록
하드웨어와 소프트웨어에 대한 인터랙티브 구성 요소와 인터페이스도 포함하고 있어요
양자 정보와 계산을요. 개요 영상과 Qiskit 교과서 링크는
설명란에서 찾으실 수 있어요.
이건 시리즈의 유닛 1의
레슨 1이에요.
유닛 1은 양자 정보의 기초를
다루고, 이 유닛의 첫 번째 레슨에서는 양자 정보가 어떻게 작동하는지에 초점을 맞출 거예요
단일 시스템에 대해서요, 즉
하나의 물리적 시스템이나 양자 정보를 저장하는 어떤 종류의 장치가
있고 그 하나의 시스템이나 장치가
독립적으로 어떻게 작동하는지를 살펴보는 거예요.
이 레슨 다음에는 여러 시스템이 있을 때
양자 정보가 어떻게 작동하는지를 논의할 거예요, 그리고 그것을 통해
여러 qubit를 사용하는
양자 알고리즘과 같은 흥미롭고 중요한 개념들을 설명할 수 있게 될 거예요
그리고 양자 정보를 처리하고
서로 주고받는 여러 개인이 관여하는 양자 프로토콜도요.
하지만 그런 논의에 들어가기 전에, 비교적
단순한 설정인 단일 시스템의 독립적인 경우부터 시작하는 게 맞아요,
부분적으로는 단순한 것부터 시작하는 게 좋기 때문이기도 하지만, 앞으로 보게 되듯이 양자 정보가 어떻게 작동하는지의 설명이
단일 시스템의 독립적인 경우에 대해 아주 자연스럽고
논리적으로 여러 시스템에 대한 양자 정보의 작동 방식 설명으로
이어지기 때문이에요.
레슨의 간략한 개요를 살펴볼게요.
먼저 고전 정보에 대해
이야기하는 것부터 시작할 거예요.
이 레슨의 목적은 고전 정보가 어떻게 작동하는지
설명하는 게 아니라, 양자 정보가 어떻게 작동하는지 설명하는 거예요,
하지만 양자 정보가 어떻게 작동하는지
설명하려면, 고전 정보부터 시작해서 양자 정보를 논의할 때 친숙한 참고점으로 사용하는 게 매우 도움이 돼요
양자 정보를 논의할 때요.
수학적 수준에서 양자 정보와 고전 정보는 실제로 꽤 비슷한 설명을 가지고 있어요, 물론 몇 가지 핵심적인 차이점이 있지만요.
사실 양자 정보는
고전 정보와 완전히 분리된 게 아니에요.
고전 정보의 확장이에요.
사실, 적어도 제 관점에서는, 고전 정보를
이해하지 못하면 양자 정보를 정말로 이해할 수 없어요,
그래서 고전 정보부터 시작하는 게
합리적이에요.
이 내용이 일부 시청자분들에게는
익숙할 거라고 생각하지만, 이미 익숙하시더라도 건너뛰지 않는 걸 권장해요.
양자 정보를 이해하는 데 가장 관련 있는 고전 정보의 측면을
강조하는 것 외에도, 이 부분에서 Dirac 표기법을 소개할 거예요,
이건 시리즈 전체에서
벡터와 행렬을 설명하는 데 사용할 표준적인 방법이에요.
알고 보면, Dirac 표기법은
양자 정보에만 특화된 게 아니에요.
고전 정보뿐만 아니라 벡터와 행렬이 등장하는 여러 다른 맥락에서도 동일하게 사용될 수 있어요.
그다음 양자 정보로 넘어갈 거예요, 구체적으로는
양자 상태의 벡터 표현을 논의할 거예요,
표준 기저 측정이라는 간단한 유형의 측정과, 양자 시스템에서 이산 시간
변화를 설명하는 유니터리 연산을요.
다시 말하지만, 모든 것이
단일 시스템의 맥락에서요.
레슨 자체를 시작하기 전에, 양자 정보에는 실제로 두 가지 설명이 있다는 걸 명확히 하는 게 도움이 될 거예요
양자 정보의 간소화된 설명, 이것이 이 레슨에서
집중할 내용이에요
그리고 이 첫 번째 유닛 전체에서요, 그리고 일반적인 설명은 나중 유닛에서,
구체적으로 시리즈의 세 번째 유닛에서 다뤄요.
간소화된 설명은 이름답게
더 단순하고 보통 먼저 배우게 돼요.
간소화된 설명에서는 이미 말씀드렸듯이 양자 상태는 벡터로 표현되고
연산은 유니터리 행렬로 표현돼요.
양자 정보에 대한 이 설명은 예를 들어
대부분의 양자 알고리즘을 이해하기에 충분해요,
그래서 지나치게 단순화된 게 아니라, 진짜예요.
하지만, 앞으로 진행하면서
발견하게 되겠지만, 몇 가지 한계가 있어요.
예를 들어, 양자 시스템에 대한 노이즈의
영향을 모델링하고 싶다면, 이 설명으로는 부족해요.
반면에 일반적인 설명은
더 일반적이고 궁극적으로 수학적 의미에서 더 강력해요.
이 설명에서 양자 상태는 밀도 행렬이라는
특별한 종류의 행렬로 표현돼요,
그리고 더 일반적인 종류의 측정과 연산을
설명할 수 있어요, 예를 들어 노이즈 같은 것도요.
이건 간소화된 설명과 완전히 일관되고
사실 간소화된 설명을
일반적인 설명의 특수한 경우로 볼 수 있어요,
그리고 고전 정보도 특수한 경우로 포함해요.
또한 모든 것이 어떻게 작동하는지 정말
아름다워요, 그래서 적절한 시기가 되면 이 일반적인 설명에 대해 배우시길 강력히 권장해요
하지만 간소화된 설명이 시작하기에 더 자연스러운 곳이에요, 그래서 우리는 그렇게 할 거예요.
고전 정보에 대해 이야기하는 것부터 시작할 건데, 양자 정보에 가장 관련 있는
고전 정보의 측면에 주목하면서
그리고 수학적으로
어떻게 설명되는지를요.
정보를 저장하는 물리적 시스템이나
어떤 종류의 장치가 있다고 상상해 보세요.
이 시스템에 X라는 이름을 붙일 건데,
이 이름에 특별한 의미는 없어요.
원한다면 다른 이름을 사용할 수도 있지만,
그냥 이름을 하나 정해서, 이 시스템을 X라고 부를게요.
X에 대해 가정을 하나 할 건데, 그건 X가 어떤 주어진 순간에
가질 수 있는 고전 상태의 유한한 집합이 있다는 거예요.
여기서 고전 상태라고 하면, 어떤 불확실성이나
오류 없이 인식되고 명확하게 설명될 수 있는 시스템의 구성을 의미해요
어떤 불확실성이나 오류도 없이요.
이건 정말 직관적으로 생각할 수 있는 거예요. 수학적 수준에서는
단순히 고전 상태의 집합을 정의하는 거예요,
원하는 대로 또는 우리가 다루는 장치를
가장 잘 설명하는 방식으로 선택하면 돼요.
이 고전 상태의 집합에 시그마라는
이름을 붙일게요, 그리고 다시 강조하면, 시그마가 유한한 집합이라고 가정하고 있어요.
이 시스템 X의 고전 상태 집합은
모든 자연수의 집합처럼 무한하게 크지 않아요.
유한해요, 그리고 그건
우리가 하는 가정이에요.
예를 들어, X가 비트일 수 있고, 이 경우 고전 상태 집합은
두 개의 원소를 포함하는 집합이에요: 0과 1.
때때로 이 집합을
이진 알파벳이라고 부르기도 해요.
또 다른 예는 X가 일반적인 육면체 주사위인 경우인데,
이 경우 고전 상태는 1부터 6까지의 숫자예요.
물론 여기서 우리는
추상화에 대해 이야기하고 있어요.
실제 육면체 주사위는 정확한 위치,
방향, 온도 등과 같은 많은 다른 속성을 가질 수 있어요,
하지만 육면체 주사위에 대해 이야기할 때 가장 일반적으로 관련 있는 정보와 관련해서는,
고전 상태는 주사위의 위쪽을 향하고 있는
면의 점 수로 표시되는 1부터 6까지의 숫자예요.
X가 집에 있을 수 있는 일반적인 전기 선풍기의
스위치라면, 아마 고전 상태는
강, 중, 약 그리고
꺼짐이 될 거예요.
이것들은 그냥 예시예요. 이것들과 다른 고전 상태
집합을 가진 시스템을 상상할 수 있지만, 이 예시들이 전달하고자 하는 건
이 고전 상태라는 개념이 익숙하고
간단하고 직관적인 용어로 이해될 수 있는 것이라는 거예요.
수학적으로 말하면, 고전 상태의 집합은
그냥 유한한 집합이고, 물론 이 집합은 비어있지 않아야 해요.
시스템이 있을 수 있는 고전 상태가
적어도 하나는 있어야 하고, 적어도 두 개의 고전 상태가 있어야
시스템이 정보를 저장하는 데 조금이라도 유용할 수 있어요.
어떤 상황에서는 X가 특정 상태에 있다는 걸
알 수도 있지만, 많은 상황에서는,
정보 처리의 맥락에서, 특정 순간에 시스템의
고전 상태에 대한 불확실성이 있을 수 있어서
각각의 가능한 고전 상태에 어떤 확률이 연관돼요.
예를 들어, X가 비트라면, X가 고전 상태 0에 있을 확률이
3/4이고 상태 1에 있을 확률이
1/4인 경우일 수 있어요.
이것을 확률적 상태라고 부를 건데,
이 확률적 상태를 여기 보이는 것처럼 표현할 수 있어요,
단순히 다른 고전 상태들에 대한
확률이 뭔지를 나타내면 돼요.
이 확률적 상태를 표현하는 더 간결한 방법은
벡터를 사용하는 거예요, 구체적으로 여기 보이는 표현은
열 벡터이고, 이 벡터는 두 개의 가능한
고전 상태에 대한 확률이 뭔지를 나타내요.
더 구체적으로, 첫 번째 항목은 X가 상태 0에 있을 확률이 뭔지를 나타내고,
두 번째 항목은 시스템이 상태 1에 있을 확률이 뭔지를 알려줘요.
이건 단순히 이진 알파벳을 정렬하는 자연스러운 방법이에요,
적어도 우리가 이렇게 하도록 훈련받은
방식이에요. 0이 먼저 오고 1이 두 번째로요.
앞으로 이런 벡터를 나타내기 위해
확률 벡터라는 용어를 사용할 거예요.
구체적으로, 모든 항목이 음이 아닌 실수이고
항목의 합이 1과 같은 벡터예요,
그래서 이 항목들을 확률로
생각하는 게 합리적이에요.
이 예시에서는 우리가 이야기하는 시스템의
고전 상태가 두 개뿐이라서 항목이 두 개예요,
하지만 일반적으로 항목은 몇 개든 있을 수 있고,
각 고전 상태마다 하나의 항목이 있다는 걸 이해하면 돼요
우리가 이야기하는 어떤 시스템이든요.
고전 정보, 확률 벡터 등에 대해
잠시 후에 계속 논의할 건데, 먼저 벡터를 설명하는
Dirac 표기법이라고 알려진
표기법을 소개하는 게 정말 도움이 될 거예요.
사실 이건 Dirac 표기법의
첫 번째 부분일 뿐이에요.
Dirac 표기법의 다른 몇 가지 측면은
레슨의 조금 뒤에서 보게 될 거예요.
이 표기법은 양자 정보를 설명하는 방식에서
아주 핵심적일 거예요, 그래서 어떻게 작동하는지 이해하는 게 필수적이에요,
하지만 다행히도 매우 간단하고 양자 정보와
구체적으로 관련된 건 전혀 아니에요,
그래서 고전 정보의 익숙한 맥락에서
지금 소개할 수 있어요.
이전처럼, 어떤 시스템의 고전 상태 집합
시그마가 있다고 가정하고, 그리고
이 고전 상태들의 순서가 있다고 가정해요,
이전 예시에서 이진 알파벳의 순서를 말했던 것처럼
이전 예시에서요. 이것을 다르게 말하면
시그마의 원소들이 1부터 정수와 대응된다는 거예요
시그마에 포함된 원소의 수만큼이요,
여기 이 표기법에서 시그마 주위의 두 줄이 의미하는 게 그거예요.
그건 시그마 집합의
원소 수예요.
그래서 첫 번째 상태,
두 번째 상태, 이런 식으로 있어요.
우리가 선택하는 특정 순서나
대응은 실제로 그렇게 중요하지 않아요.
정말 중요한 건 순서를 정하고
그걸 일관되게 유지하는 거예요.
우리가 마주치게 될 많은 고전 상태 집합에는
이진 알파벳처럼 표준적인 순서가 있을 거예요,
표준적인 순서가 없으면, 그냥 하나를 선택하면 돼요.
하지만 어떤 것이든, 일관되게 유지한다는 게 전제예요.
자, 이제 소개되는
표기법이 이거예요.
시그마 집합에서 고전 상태 a를 선택할 때,
여기 보이는 것을 쓰는데, 이건 ket a라고 읽고, 이것은 열 벡터를 의미해요
a에 해당하는 항목에 1이 있고 다른 모든 항목에는 0이 있는 벡터예요.
예를 들어, 이진 알파벳으로 돌아가면,
짐작하셨겠지만 이건 아주 중요한 예시로
계속해서 다시 돌아올 거예요. ket 0과 ket 1은 여기 정의된 벡터예요.
ket 0은 고전 상태 0에 해당하는 항목,
즉 첫 번째 항목에 1이 있는 벡터이고,
다른 모든 항목에는 0이 있어요,
이 경우 다른 항목은 하나뿐이에요.
마찬가지로, ket 1은 여기 보이는
벡터인데, 1에 해당하는 항목에 1이 있고,
그건 두 번째 항목이에요, 그리고 다른 모든 항목에는 0이 있어요, 역시 항목 하나뿐이에요.
또 다른 예시가 있어요. 이 예시에서는
고전 상태 집합 시그마가 표준 카드 덱의 네 가지 무늬에 해당해요
표준 카드 덱의: 클럽, 다이아몬드, 하트, 스페이드예요.
이 경우 이 무늬들의 보편적으로 합의된
순서는 실제로 없어요.
많은 카드 게임에서 순서는 아예 없어요. 그냥 네 개의 다른 무늬가 있을 뿐이고 그게 전부예요, 그리고 이 무늬들에 순서를 매기는 다른 카드 게임도 있지만
다른 방식으로요, 하지만 실제로 중요하지 않아요.
여기 보이는 것처럼
순서를 하나 그냥 선택하면 돼요.
이건 영어로 쓴 이 네 무늬의 이름에 따른 알파벳순이에요,
이 특정 순서를 선택했다고 가정하면,
이 네 벡터를 정의해요: ket 클럽, ket 다이아몬드, ket 하트, 그리고 ket 스페이드
여기 보이는 것처럼요, 그리고 이 벡터들은
여기 위에 보이는 일반적인 설명에 해당해요.
이 네 무늬에 대해 이 특정 순서를
선택했다는 전제하에요.
우리가 선택하는 어떤 고전 상태 집합에 대해서도
같은 걸 할 수 있어요.
고전 상태 집합은 항상
유한하고 비어있지 않은 집합을 의미한다는 걸 기억하세요.
이런 형태의 벡터를 표준 기저 벡터라고 부르고,
모든 벡터는 표준 기저 벡터의 선형 결합으로 유일하게 표현될 수 있다는 건 매우 기본적인 사실이에요
표준 기저 벡터의
선형 결합으로요.
예를 들어, 방금 전 예시로 돌아가면,
우리가 본 확률 벡터는 이렇게 표현될 수 있어요
여기 보이는 것처럼요. 이건 기본적으로 벡터를 표현하는
대안적인 방법이에요
앞으로 여러 가지 이유로 매우 편리할 거예요.
이제 이 표기법을 손에 쥐었으니, 고전 정보와
특히 확률적 상태에 대한 논의로 돌아가 볼게요.
어떤 확률적 상태에 있는 시스템을
측정하면 무슨 일이 일어나는지 생각해 봐요.
고전적인 맥락에서 측정이나 뭔가를
측정하는 행위를 보통 언급하지는 않지만, 이 용어는 말이 돼요.
본질적으로, 이 맥락에서 시스템 X를
측정한다는 건 그냥 그걸 보고 어떤 상태에 있든 인식한다는 의미예요.
물론 시스템을 볼 때 확률적 상태가 보이는 게 아니라, 고전 상태가 보여요,
그리고 우리가 보는 특정 고전 상태는
확률에 따라 무작위로 선택된 것으로 상상할 수 있어요.
우리가 보는 고전 상태가 측정하거나
시스템을 보는 순간에 어떻게든 무작위로 선택된다는 개념에 철학적으로 반대할 수도 있어요,
시스템은 단순히 처음부터 어떤 특정 고전 상태에
있었고
우리가 그 상태가 뭐였는지 알게 된 것뿐이에요,
하지만 우리가 다루는 수학적 프레임워크의 관점에서 생각하면,
이렇게 생각해도 괜찮고 이렇게 하면 양자 정보와의
유사점을 조금 후에 그릴 수 있어요.
우리가 보는 고전 상태가 고전 상태 a라고
가정해 봐요, a는 시그마 집합의 어떤 상태든 될 수 있어요.
이건 일반적으로, 적어도 우리 관점에서는
X의 확률적 상태를 변경해요.
확률은 더 이상 의미가 없어요
왜냐하면 이제 X의 고전 상태가 뭔지 알기 때문이에요.
그건 a이고, 더 이상
이에 대한 불확실성이 없어요.
그래서 이제 시스템이 상태 a에 있을
확률이 1이라고 말할 거예요.
이걸 아는 이유는 방금 봤고 고전 상태가 a인 걸 확인했기 때문이에요, 그래서 X의 새로운 확률적 상태는
고전 상태 a에 있을 확률이
1인 상태예요.
그리고 그 확률적 상태는
확률 벡터 ket a로 표현돼요.
고전 상태 a에 해당하는 항목에 1이 있고 다른 모든 항목에는 0이 있어요.
예를 들어, 다시 X가 비트인 상황을
생각하고 이전과 같은 확률적 상태가 있다면,
X를 측정하면
전이가 일어나는 것으로 상상할 수 있어요.
3/4의 확률로 고전 상태 0을 보고,
측정함으로써 ket 0이 우리의 확률적 상태가 되는 것으로 전이하고,
1/4의 확률로 ket 1으로 전이해요.
이것을 실제 물리적 전이가 아니라
지식의 전이라고 생각해도 돼요,
하지만 이 레슨에서 중요한 건
수학이 어떻게 작동하는지 인식하는 거예요.
사실 꽤 자명한 건데, 이 자명함을 인식함으로써
양자 설정에서의 유사한 설명이
조금 덜 신비로워 보일 수 있어요.
마지막으로 한 가지는, 우리가 측정했을 때
X의 고전 상태가 뭐였는지 보지 못한 다른 사람에게는,
확률적 상태가 우리가
측정한 결과로 당연히 변하지 않을 거예요.
그건 괜찮아요. 서로 다른 사람들이
특정 시스템에 대해 다른 지식을 가질 수 있고, 그에 따라 다른 확률적 상태를 선택할 수 있어요
그 시스템에 대한 자신의
지식을 나타내기 위해서요.
이 고전 정보 논의의 마지막 부분에서는 시스템에 수행할 수 있는 고전 연산에 대해 이야기할 건데,
결정론적 연산부터 시작할게요.
시스템에 연산을 수행하면 일반적으로 그 결과로 상태가 변하고, 이 맥락에서 결정론적이라는 단어는
연산 수행의 결과가 연산이 수행되기 전에
시스템이 있던 고전 상태에 전적으로 의존한다는 의미예요
연산이 수행되기 전에요.
다시 말해, 결정론적 연산이 수행될 때는
우연의 요소가 없어요, 그래서 무작위성이나 불확실성이 관여하지 않아요.
수학적 용어로, 결정론적 연산은
함수로 설명돼요.
여기 보이는 형태의 모든 함수 f는,
함수의 입력과 출력 모두
고전 상태 집합 시그마의 원소에
해당한다는 의미이고, 이것이 결정론적 연산을 설명해요.
고전 상태 a는 상태 a의 각 선택에 대해
f(a) 상태로 변환돼요.
이런 형태의 모든 함수 f에 대해, 여기 보이는
이 조건을 만족하는 유일한 행렬 M이 항상 존재해요,
그건 M을 벡터 ket a에 곱하면
벡터 ket f(a)를 준다는 거예요,
그리고 이건 고전 상태 a의
모든 선택에 대해 참이에요.
이런 형태의 어떤 함수 f를 선택하든,
M의 명시적 설명을 쓰는 건 그리 어렵지 않아요.
항상 각 열에 정확히 하나의 1이 있고
나머지 항목은 모두 0이에요.
그리고 여기 공식이 있어요. M의 b, a 항목은 b가 f(a)와 같으면 1이고
그렇지 않으면 0이에요, 여기서 이것은
행이 b에 해당하고 열이 a에 해당하는 M의 항목을 의미해요
그리고 열이 a에 해당하는 거예요.
잠시 후에 몇 가지 예시를 보면서, 이 공식이 왜 맞는지 살펴볼 거예요.
함수를 가져와서 이런 식으로 행렬로 표현하는 게 왜 필요한지 명확하지 않을 수 있는데,
이렇게 하는 게 맞아요. 그 이유 중 하나, 아마 주된 이유는, 시스템이 확률적 상태에 있고
그 시스템에 결정론적 연산을 수행하면,
결과 확률적 상태는
행렬-벡터 곱셈으로 구할 수 있다는 거예요, 즉 시스템이
확률적 상태에 있고
어떤 확률 벡터 v로 표현되고
M으로 설명되는 결정론적 연산을
그 시스템에 수행하면, 결과 확률적 상태는 M 곱하기 v로 주어져요.
여기서 참고로, 이렇게 막대가 있는 화살표는
수학에서 한 것이 다른 것으로
매핑되거나 변환됨을 나타내는 일반적인 표기법이에요. 그냥 보통 화살표를 쓸 수도 있지만, 이게 관례적이고
인식하기 쉽고, 여러 가지 의미를 가질 수 있는 그냥 화살표보다 좀 더 구체적일 수 있어요.
이제 예시를 살펴보죠, 사실 여러 예시의 모음이에요.
고전 상태 집합 시그마를 다시 이진 알파벳으로 설정하면 어떻게 되는지 생각해 봐요.
이 고전 상태 집합일 때 우리가 논의한 형태의 함수는 많지 않고, 더 정확히 말하면, 이 형태의 함수는 딱 네 개예요.
여기, 그 네 함수가 소위 값의 표로 설명돼 있어요.
첫 번째 표는 f1이라고
이름 붙인 첫 번째 함수를 설명해요.
왼쪽의 각 가능한 입력에 대해 오른쪽에
대응하는 출력을 나열하면, f1(0)은 0이고,
f1(1)도 역시 0이에요, 즉 f1은
상수 0 함수예요.
항상 값 0을 가져요.
두 번째 함수 f2는
항등 함수예요.
두 번째 표에서 볼 수 있듯이 출력은 항상 입력과 같아요.
세 번째 함수 f3는
세 번째 표로 설명돼요.
f3(0)은 1이고, f3(1)은 0이에요.
이 함수는 NOT 함수 또는
논리 부정으로 더 잘 알려져 있어요.
0을 1로, 1을 0으로 뒤집기 때문에
비트 플립이라고도 불러요.
마지막 함수 f4는 첫 번째 것처럼
역시 상수 함수인데, 이건 상수 1 함수예요
왜냐하면 항상 값 1을 가지기 때문이에요.
그리고 이것들이 이진 알파벳에서 자기 자신으로의 유일한 네 함수예요.
여기 이전의 공식으로 설명되는 이 네 함수에
대응하는 네 행렬이 있어요,
여기서 볼 수 있듯이, 원하시면 영상을 멈추고 확인해 볼 수 있어요.
행렬에서 인덱스의 순서는 항상 행이 먼저, 열이 두 번째라는 걸 기억하세요.
그래서 b, a 항목은 행 b와 열 a에 해당하거나
고전 상태 b에 해당하는 행과
고전 상태 a에 해당하는
열이에요.
예를 들어, 첫 번째 함수를 보면,
f1(0)은 0이고
그에 따라 M1의
0, 0 항목은 1이에요.
그런데 여기 있는 1, 0 항목은
0이에요, 그리고 입력이 1인 경우에 대해서도 같은 걸 할 수 있고
마찬가지로 나머지 세 함수에
대해서도요.
이전의 이 공식이 참인지 확인할 수도 있는데,
모든 다른 가능성을 하나하나 살펴보면서 검증하면 돼요.
그리고 사실 행렬 곱셈이 어떻게 작동하는지
생각해 보면, 정말 그냥 눈으로 봐도 알 수 있어요.
이런 식으로 행렬을 표준 기저 벡터에 곱하면,
입력을 가져와서
ket 안의 고전 상태에 해당하는 열의
행렬 위쪽으로 떨어뜨리는 걸 상상할 수 있고,
그리고 나오는 출력은 단순히
그 열을 확률 벡터로 한 거예요.
예를 들어, M3에 ket 0을
곱하면 0, 1을 얻고
확률 벡터로서 그건 ket 1이에요.
M3에 ket 1을 곱하면
1, 0을 얻는데, 그건 ket 0이에요, 이런 식이에요.
확률적 상태에 대한 연산은 잠시 후에
더 논의할 건데, 먼저 Dirac 표기법의 두 번째 부분을 소개할게요.
이건 연산에 대해 이야기하고 행렬로 생각하는 데
도움이 될 거고, 앞으로 계속 사용할 표준 도구이기도 해요
앞으로 계속요. 설정은 이전과 같아요.
우리가 다루는 어떤 고전 상태 집합 시그마가 있고,
그 고전 상태들을 정렬하는 어떤 방법이 있다고 가정해요.
그러면 여기 보이는 것을 쓰는데, 이번에는
꺾쇠 막대가 오른쪽이 아니라 왼쪽에 있어요, 이건 1이 있는 행 벡터를 의미해요
a에 해당하는 항목에 1이 있고
다른 모든 고전 상태에 해당하는 다른 모든 항목에는 0이 있는 거예요.
그래서 이것과 ket a의 차이는
이것은 행 벡터이고 ket a는 열 벡터라는 거예요,
하지만 그 외에는 벡터가
비슷한 방식으로 정의돼요.
이걸 bra a라고 읽어요, 웃긴 건지 모르겠지만,
아이디어는 bra와 ket이라는 이름이
bracket이라는 단어의 두 반쪽이라는 거예요,
이에 대해 잠시 후에 더 이야기할 거예요.
하지만 먼저 아주 간단한
예시를 살펴볼게요.
이진 알파벳의 경우, bra 0은 ket a와
유사한 여기 이 행 벡터인데,
열 벡터가 아니라 행 벡터라는 것만 다르고,
bra 1은 여기 이 벡터예요.
일반적으로, 행 벡터를 열 벡터에 곱하면,
이것들을 행 하나 또는 열 하나만 있는 행렬로 생각하면
1 곱하기 1 행렬을 얻는데,
이건 스칼라로 생각할 수 있어요.
여기서 참고로, 이 별표들은
임의의 숫자를 나타내는 것으로 생각하면 돼요.
특히, 행 벡터 bra a를
열 벡터 ket b에 곱하면,
두 가지 일이 일어날 수 있어요.
하나는 a와 b가 같은 경우, 즉 같은 고전 상태인 경우인데,
이때 1들이 정렬되고
곱은 1이 돼요, 또는 a와 b가
다른 경우도 있는데,
그러면 1들이 정렬되지 않고 곱은 0이에요.
이 관찰들을 간단하게 표현하는
방법은 여기 이렇게예요.
그리고 깔끔하게 유지하기 위해, 이 곱을 이렇게 중간에 막대 하나만 두고 쓰는데,
이건 여기 이것과 정확히 같은 의미예요.
이제 bra와 ket이 합쳐져서 bracket을
이루는 걸 볼 수 있는데, 이건 내적이라고도 불리고,
그건 매우 중요한 거라서
레슨 3에서 다시 돌아올 거예요.
반면에 열 벡터를 행 벡터에 곱하면,
여기서 볼 수 있듯이 행렬을 얻어요.
예를 들어, 다시 이진 알파벳으로 돌아가서,
ket 0에 bra 0을 곱하면,
여기 이 행렬을 얻어요, 그리고 다른 가능성을
살펴보면 무슨 일이 일어나는지 볼 수 있어요.
ket 0 곱하기 bra 1은 여기 이 행렬을 줘요,
1이 이 위치로 이동했어요.
ket 1, bra 0은 이렇게 생겼고, 여기 ket 1, bra 1이에요.
보이는 건, 그 외에는 모두 0인 행렬에 하나의 1만 있고, 그 1의 위치는
bra와 ket에서 어떤
고전 상태를 선택하느냐에 따라 결정돼요.
더 정확히 말하면, 이건 어떤 고전 상태 집합을
선택하든 일반적으로 참인데, ket a에 bra b를 곱해서 얻는 행렬은
a, b 항목에 1이 있고 다른 모든 항목에 0이 있는 행렬이에요.
이제 Dirac 표기법의 첫 번째와 두 번째 부분을 모두 가지게 되어서,
연산과 행렬을 연결하는 매우 편리한 도구가 생겼어요.
결정론적 연산으로 잠시 돌아가서,
레슨 앞부분에서
여기 이 형태의 모든 함수 f에 대해, a를 f(a)로
변환하는 결정론적 연산이 있다고 말했었고
각 가능한 고전 상태 a에 대해서요. 그리고 이런 함수에 대해
표준 기저 상태에 이렇게 작용하는 유일한 행렬 M이 항상 존재한다고 했어요
표준 기저 상태에 대해서요.
Dirac 표기법을 사용하면, 이 행렬을 여기 보이는 것처럼 매우 쉽게 표현할 수 있고,
때때로 Dirac 표기법의 프레임워크 안에서
행렬을 완전히 다룰 수 있다는 걸 볼 수 있어요
벡터와 행렬, 즉 숫자로 채워진
직사각형으로 명시적으로 변환하지 않고도요.
이 경우, M을 ket a에 곱해서
필요한 공식이 참인지 확인할 수 있어요.
M에 대한 표현을 이렇게 대입하고,
괄호를 제거하고 bra b와 ket a를 이렇게 결합할 수 있어요.
이건 행렬 곱셈이 선형이기 때문인데,
이 경우 첫 번째 인수에 대해 선형이고 결합법칙이 성립해서 괄호를 제거할 수 있어요.
이제 고정된 a에 대해 모든 가능한
b의 선택에 대해 합산할 때,
여기 이 bracket은 b가 a와 같지 않을 때
항상 0이 돼서, 합에 기여하지 않고,
b가 a와 같을 때는 bracket이 1이 되어서
여기 이 하나의 항만 남게 돼요.
이게 우리가 원하던 공식이고, 그래서 함수를 행렬로 표현하는 매우 깔끔하고 간단한 방법을 가지게 됐어요.
결정론적 연산 외에도, 시스템의 고전 상태에 대해
무작위성이나 불확실성을 자체적으로 도입하는 연산도 있어요.
이런 연산을 확률적 연산이라는 용어로 부르고, 정확히 말하면 확률적 연산이라고 할 때,
무작위성을 도입할 수 있는 연산을 의미해요,
그래서 결정론적 연산은 사실 확률적 연산의 특수한 경우로
그냥 무작위성을 도입하지 않는
경우예요.
무작위성이 도입되는
간단한 예시가 있어요.
이건 단일 비트에 대한 연산이에요. 작동 방식은
비트의 고전 상태가 0이면,
아무 일도 일어나지 않아요. 비트는 0으로 유지되지만, 비트의
고전 상태가 1이면, 연산은 비트를 0으로 뒤집어요
1/2의 확률로요.
이 연산에 특별한 이름은 없어요,
적어도 제가 아는 한은요.
그냥 예시일 뿐이지만, 비트에
이 연산을 수행하는 걸 상상할 수 있어요.
결정론적 연산과 마찬가지로, 확률적 연산도
행렬로 표현될 수 있고 확률적 상태에 대한 작용은
이전처럼 행렬-벡터 곱셈으로 주어져요.
이번에는 행렬이 각 열에 정확히 하나의 1이 있고 나머지는 0인 경우가 반드시 아닐 수 있어요.
확률적 연산은 더 일반적으로
확률 행렬로 표현돼요.
이것들은 모든 항목이 음이 아닌 실수이고
각 열의 항목 합이 1인 행렬이에요.
이건 확률 행렬이 모든 열이
확률 벡터를 이루는 행렬이라고 말하는 것과 같아요.
표준 기저 벡터에 대한 행렬의 작용을
생각하면 이해가 돼요.
원하는 고전 상태를 골라서 그 고전 상태에 해당하는
열의 행렬 위쪽으로 그 상태를 떨어뜨리는 걸 상상하면,
그 열이 확률 벡터로서
나오는 확률적 상태가 뭔지 알려줘요.
예를 들어, 우리 예시의 확률적 연산은
여기 이 행렬로 설명돼요.
이 연산을 고전 상태 0에 수행하면,
첫 번째 열에 의해 주어지는 확률적 상태를 얻는데,
그건 다시 고전 상태 0이에요, 또는 동등하게
0이 확률 1로 발생하는 확률적 상태예요.
대신 이 연산을 고전 상태 1에 수행하면,
사실상 비트를 무작위화하는 거고, 그에 따라 여기 이 확률 벡터를 얻어요
각 가능한 상태에 대한 확률이
1/2인 거예요.
일반적으로, 이 연산을 어떤 확률적 상태에 수행하면, 효과는 본질적으로
두 열 사이의 가중 평균이에요
왜냐하면 행렬-벡터 곱셈이
그렇게 작동하니까요.
선형이니까, 두 가능한
결과를 그에 맞게 평균내는 거예요.
확률적 연산을 이런 방식으로 생각하면,
무작위성을 도입하거나 주입하는 것으로 생각하는 게 자연스러워요.
열을 하나씩 읽으면서 각 가능한 고전 상태에 대해
도입하는 무작위성을 볼 수 있어요.
확률적 연산을 약간 다른 방식으로도
생각할 수 있는데, 그건 결정론적 연산의 무작위 선택이에요.
예를 들어, 우리 예시에서 이 연산을
공정한 동전 던지기와 동등하게 생각할 수 있어요
상수 0 함수 또는 항등 함수를
각각 1/2의 확률로 수행하는 거예요,
그리고 이 방정식에서
바로 그걸 반영하는 걸 볼 수 있어요.
이건 어떤 확률적 연산에 대해서든
항상 가능하고, 꽤 직관적이에요.
어떤 과정의 일부로 무작위 선택을 했다면,
항상 그 무작위 선택을 미리 해서
그 선택들을 결정론적 연산의
어떤 모음에 하드코딩할 수 있다고 상상할 수 있어요.
확률적 연산을 이런 방식으로 생각하는 게
때때로 꽤 도움이 되고, 몇 레슨 후에 이에 대한 예시를 볼 거예요.
이 레슨에서 고전 정보에 대해 마지막으로 할 말은
확률적 연산의 합성에 관한 건데, 그건 하나를 다른 것 다음에 수행한다는 뜻이에요.
X라는 시스템이 있고 M1부터 Mn까지가
X에 대한 확률적 연산을 나타내는 확률 행렬이라고 가정해요.
어떤 순간 X의 확률적 상태를 나타내는
확률 벡터 v가 있다고 상상하고, 먼저
행렬 M1로 표현되는 첫 번째 확률적 연산을 X에 적용하고,
그다음 두 번째 확률적 연산을 적용해요,
그건 M2로 표현돼요.
그렇게 하면, 첫 번째 연산만 적용한 후
얻는 확률 벡터는 M1 곱하기 v이고,
두 번째 연산을 적용하면,
결과 확률 벡터는 M1을 적용한 후 얻은 어떤 벡터에 M2를 곱한 거예요
M1을 적용한 후에요. 그래서 이렇게 보여요.
행렬 곱셈은 결합 법칙이 성립하는 연산이에요,
이건 괄호를 어디에 두든 상관없다는 의미예요.
그래서 괄호를 이렇게
쉽게 옮길 수 있어요.
매우 간단하지만 흥미롭기도 한데, 먼저 M1을
적용하고 그다음 M2를 적용하는 연산을
하나의 연산으로
생각할 수 있다는 걸 보여주기 때문이에요.
다시 말해, 첫 번째와 두 번째 확률적 연산을
합성해서 얻는 확률적 연산은 행렬 곱 M2 곱하기 M1로 표현되고,
그건 어떤 확률적 상태에서
시작했든 같은 연산이에요.
이 합성된 연산을 생각하거나 설명하기 위해
확률 벡터 v에 대해 아무것도 알 필요가 없어요.
여기서 순서가 M2가 왼쪽이고 M1이
오른쪽인 걸 주목하세요, 이건 오른쪽에 있는 행렬 M1이
벡터 v에 곱해지는 거고,
M2는 M1을 곱한 후 얻은 어떤 벡터에 곱해지기 때문이에요.
그래서 순서가 어떤 의미에서는
뒤집힌다는 걸 항상 기억해야 해요.
먼저 수행되는 연산이 오른쪽에 있고,
마지막에 수행되는 연산, 이 경우 두 번째가 왼쪽에 있어요.
두 번째 연산에서 멈추지 않고 첫 번째부터 시작해서
마지막 Mn까지 순서대로 모두 적용하면,
이 모든 연산들을 합성한 것은
여기 보이는 이 곱으로 주어지고,
순서가 이전과 정확히 같은 이유로
다시 뒤집혀 있는 걸 볼 수 있어요.
요약하면, 확률적 연산의 합성은
그것들을 나타내는 확률 행렬의 곱으로 표현돼요.
곱에서 행렬의 순서가
이렇다는 걸 기억하세요.
확률 행렬의 곱을 취하면 항상 확률 행렬을 얻고,
때때로 이 사실을 이렇게 표현해요
확률 행렬이 곱셈에 대해 닫혀 있다고요,
이걸 생각하는 방식은 확률 행렬의 집합 밖으로 나갈 수 없다는 거예요
곱해도요, 왜냐하면 그 집합은 닫혀 있으니까요.
이 곱에서 행렬의 순서로 돌아가면,
순서가 정말로 중요하다는 걸 아는 게 중요해요.
행렬 곱셈은 교환 법칙이 성립하지 않아요. 곱에서
행렬의 순서를 바꾸면 결과가 바뀔 수 있어요,
그리고 결정론적 연산보다
더 멀리 볼 필요도 없어요.
여기 순서가 중요한 결정론적 연산을 나타내는
두 확률 행렬의 간단한 예시가 있어요.
M1은 상수 0 함수를 나타내요. 이전 예시처럼 이 두 연산이 비트에 대한 거라고 상상해요.
M2는 NOT 연산 또는
비트 플립을 나타내요.
M1을 먼저 수행하고 M2를 수행하면,
결과는 여기 이 행렬인데, 상수 1 함수를 나타내요.
비트를 0으로 설정한 다음 뒤집으면,
그 비트를 1로 설정하는 것과 같아요.
반면에 M2를 먼저 수행하고
M1을 수행하면, 결과는 여기예요,
이게 말이 되는 건 비트를 뒤집고 나서
0으로 설정하면, 그냥 0으로 설정하는 것과 같기 때문이에요.
뒤집은 건 의미가 없어요. 분명히 이 두 행렬은
같지 않고, 그래서 순서가 중요하다는 걸 보여주는
매우 간단한 예시가 돼요. 물론 이건 전혀 놀랍지 않아요.
연산이 수행되는 순서가 중요하다는 건
우리 모두 알고 있어요, 적어도 중요할 수 있다는 건요.
예를 들어, 성냥에 불을 붙이고 나서
바람을 불면, 먼저 바람을 불고 나서
불을 붙이는 것과 결과가 매우 달라요. 이 시점에서 고전 정보에 대해
꽤 많이 이야기했고 이제 드디어 양자 정보를 논의할 시간이에요.
그리고 수학적으로 양자 정보가 고전 정보와
매우 비슷한 방식으로 작동한다는 걸 발견하게 될 거예요, 몇 가지 핵심 차이점과 함께요.
첫 번째 핵심 차이점은
바로 시작 부분에 있어요, 상태를 정의하는 방법, 이 경우 시스템의 양자 상태를요,
그리고 양자 상태를 정의하는 이 하나의 선택이
양자 정보가 어떻게 작동하는지를 크게 결정한다는 면이 있어요.
측정과 연산이 어떻게 작동하는지도
정의할 거고, 다음 레슨에서는 양자 정보가 단일 시스템뿐만 아니라 여러 시스템에 대해 어떻게 작동하는지 논의할 거예요,
하지만 이것들은 사실 단일 시스템의
독립적인 양자 상태 개념이 확립되면 꽤 자연스럽게 따라와요.
정의는 이거예요. 시스템의 양자 상태는 인덱스가
그 시스템의 고전 상태와
대응되는 열 벡터로 표현돼요.
여기서 우리가 이야기하는 시스템에
고전 정보와 확률적 상태를 이야기했을 때처럼 고전 상태의 집합이 있다고 가정하고 있어요.
양자 상태 벡터의 항목은 확률적 경우에서
항목이 음이 아닌 실수인 것과 달리 복소수예요
확률적 경우에서는 항목이
음이 아닌 실수인 것과요.
그리고 이번에는 확률적 경우에서 합이 1인 것과 달리
항목의 절대값 제곱의 합이 1이어야 해요
확률적 경우에서처럼요.
양자 상태 벡터에 나타나는 복소수를
때때로 진폭이라고 부르고, 확률과 비슷한 역할을 하지만,
확률이 아니고 같은 해석을
가지지 않아요.
양자 상태가 왜 이렇게 정의되어야 하는지에 대해
물리학자들이 이 정의가 물리적으로 관련 있다는 걸 발견했다는 것 외에는
좋은 이유를 드릴 수 없어요,
그리고 이것이 양자역학 시스템을 설명하고 모델링할 수 있게 해줘요.
다시 말해, 이 정의를 선택하는 건
효과가 있기 때문이지, 양자 상태가 이렇게 정의되어야 하는 특별한 이유가 있어서가 아니에요.
이 양자 상태 개념의 수학에 대해,
이해하고 다루기 위한 첫 번째 단계는 벡터의 유클리드 노름에 대한 이 정의를 떠올리는 거예요,
기하학적으로 벡터의 길이라고 생각할 수 있는데, 2차원 실수 벡터를 종이 위에 원점에서 시작하는 화살표로 그리는
보통 방식에서 길이를 생각하는 것처럼요.
구체적으로, 이렇게 생긴 열 벡터 v가 있고,
복소수 항목 알파 1부터 알파 n까지가 있다고 가정하면,
v의 유클리드 노름은 여기 보이는 것처럼 정의돼요.
이것이 유클리드 노름에 사용하는 표기법인데,
우리가 이야기하는 벡터 주위에 이중 막대를 넣어요.
이 경우 v이고, 유클리드 노름이 정의되는 방식은
벡터 항목의
절대값 제곱의 합의
제곱근이에요.
그래서 양자 상태 벡터가 뭔지를 정의하는 또 다른 방법은,
양자 상태 벡터는 복소수 항목을 가진 열 벡터로
유클리드 노름이 1인 거예요, 즉 유클리드 노름에 대한 단위 벡터라는 거예요.
그건 절대값 제곱의 합이 1일 때만
유클리드 노름이 1이기 때문이에요.
절대값 제곱의 합이 1이면
제곱근은 아무것도 바꾸지 않아요.
그래서 양자 상태 벡터가 뭔지 설명하면요. 시스템의 고전 상태에 대응하는
인덱스를 가진 열 벡터로
복소수 항목을 가지고 유클리드 노름이 1인 거예요.
이것이 의미하는 것, 또는 함축하는 것, 또는 어떻게 해석해야 하는지는
다른 문제이고 어떤 의미에서는,
양자 정보와 계산의 연구는
이 정의가 무엇을 함축하는지에 대한 탐구예요, 적어도 정보 처리 측면에서는요.
이건 단순히 출발점이에요.
참고로, 유클리드 노름 외에도 다른 소위 노름이 있고,
벡터 주위의 이중 막대 표기법이
항상 유클리드 노름을
의미하는 건 아니에요.
다른 맥락에서 이 표기법은
다른 노름을 가리킬 수 있어요.
예를 들어, 제곱이나 제곱근 없이
절대값의 합은 다른 노름이에요,
보통 1-노름이라고 불러요.
사실 꽤 많은 다른 노름이 있어요.
때때로 이 표기법이 두 번째 막대 세트 뒤에
아래 첨자와 함께 사용되어 어떤 노름을 이야기하는지 더 많은 정보를 제공해요.
그리고 그렇게 할 때, 아래 첨자로 숫자 2가
유클리드 노름을 의미하는 게 꽤 일반적이에요.
하지만 이 시리즈에서는 이런 열 벡터가 있을 때,
이 이중 막대 표기법만으로
유클리드 노름을 의미해요.
여기 양자 상태 벡터의 몇 가지 예시가 있고,
이 특정 양자 상태 벡터들은 qubit 상태 벡터예요,
즉 시스템의 고전 상태가
0과 1이라는 뜻이에요.
qubit이라는 단어는 quantum bit의 줄임말로,
사실상 양자 상태에 있을 수 있는 비트예요.
처음 두 예시는 정말 간단해요. 표준 기저 벡터
ket 0과 ket 1은 양자 상태 벡터예요.
둘 다 열 벡터이고, 인덱스가
고전 상태 0과 1에 대응하고, 이 벡터들의 항목은 복소수예요.
이 특정 벡터들의 항목은 0과 1인데, 실수이고 사실 정수이지만, 허수 부분이 0인 복소수이기도 해요
허수 부분이 0인
복소수이기도 해요.
각 벡터에는 1인 항목 하나와 0인 항목 하나가 있어요.
그래서 항목의 절대값을 합하면,
두 경우 모두 1을 얻어요.
그래서 이 벡터들이 양자 상태 벡터가 되기 위한
조건이 충족돼요.
다음 두 예시는 플러스 상태와 마이너스 상태라고 불리는 매우 흔하게 만나는 qubit 상태예요.
화면에서 보이듯이 ket 플러스 또는
ket 마이너스로 표기되고, 여기 보이는 것처럼 정의돼요.
역시 이 벡터들의 항목은 복소수예요. 이번에는
양의 1/루트2 또는 음의 1/루트2이고,
절대값 제곱을 합하면,
1/2 더하기 1/2, 즉 1을 얻어요.
참고로, 이렇게 ket 안에 플러스 기호나
마이너스 기호를 넣는 게 좀 이상하게 보일 수 있는데, 이것들은 시스템의 고전 상태가 아니거든요,
하지만 이 표기법은 그럼에도 사용되고, 잠시 후에 이에 대해 다시 이야기할 거예요.
하지만 지금 간단히 말하면, Dirac 표기법을 사용해서 벡터에 원하는 이름을 ket 안에 넣을 수 있어요.
Dirac 표기법을 사용할 때
벡터가 반드시 표준 기저 벡터일 필요는 없어요.
당분간 마지막 qubit 상태
예시가 있어요.
특별한 이름이 없고 특별히 의미 있지도 않은 qubit의 양자 상태 벡터예요.
이 벡터의 항목은 (1 + 2i)/3과
-2/3이에요.
이것들은 복소수이고, 이 두 항목의 절대값 제곱을
계산하면, 첫 번째는 5/9를 얻고
두 번째는 4/9를 얻어요. 그래서 절대값 제곱의
합은 1이에요.
그리고 마지막 예시가 하나 있어요. 이번에는
고전 상태가 네 가지 카드 무늬인 시스템이에요.
고전 상태가 네 가지 카드 무늬인 시스템이 양자 상태에 있는 게 왜 필요한지 모르겠지만,
원칙적으로는 가능하고
그냥 예시로 든 거예요.
다른 무늬에 해당하는 항목은
클럽은 1/2, 다이아몬드는 -i/2이고,
하트는 합에 나타나지 않아서 0이고,
스페이드는 1/루트2예요.
그리고 이전에 정렬했던 것처럼
고전 상태를 정렬했다고 가정하면 열 벡터로 보면 이렇게 생겼어요,
여기 보이는 순서가
그 순서예요.
이 항목들의 절대값 제곱을 취하면
첫 번째는 1/4, 다음 것도 1/4이에요.
0의 절대값 제곱은 0이니까,
그 항목은 합에 기여하지 않아요.
마지막으로 마지막 것은 1/2를 얻어요. 그래서 이 벡터가 양자 상태 벡터가 되기 위해
필요한 대로 합은 1이에요.
방금 전에 표준 기저 벡터가 아닌 두 qubit 상태 벡터를
가리키기 위해 ket 플러스와 ket 마이너스 표기법을 사용했어요.
이 점에 대해 잠시 돌아가서
Dirac 표기법이 표준 기저 벡터뿐만 아니라 임의의 벡터에 어떻게 사용되는지 설명할게요.
이미 언급했듯이, bra나 ket 안에 원하는
이름을 사용해서 벡터를 가리킬 수 있어요.
ket은 열 벡터이고
bra는 이전과 마찬가지로 행 벡터예요.
예를 들어, 그리스 문자 프사이는
임의의 벡터를 가리키기 위해 ket 안에 매우 흔하게 사용돼요,
여기서는 특별한 이름이 없는
이전의 상태 벡터에 이름을 부여하는 데 사용하고 있어요.
이렇게 할 때, 문자 프사이 자체가
반드시 의미를 가지는 건 아니에요.
그냥 벡터의 이름이고, 열 벡터라는 걸
명확히 하기 위해 ket 안에 있는 거예요.
때때로 좀 혼동될 수 있고,
프사이라는 문자가 어떤 시스템의 고전 상태와 연관될 수 있다면 모호성의 가능성이 있어요
예를 들어요, 하지만 일반적으로
문제를 일으키지 않고, 원하지 않으면 Dirac 표기법을 이렇게 사용하지 않아도 돼요
ket 없이 u, v, w 같은 소문자를 사용하는 것도
열 벡터를 나타내는 좋은 방법이에요
더 구체적으로는
양자 상태 벡터를요.
자신을 표현하기 위해 어떤 표기법을
사용할지는 여러분의 선택이에요.
중요한 건 첫째, 표현하려는 것의
의미가 다른 사람에게 명확해야 한다는 거예요.
그리고 둘째, 다른 사람들의 표기법 선호가
여러분의 것과 같지 않더라도 그들이 표현하려는 걸 이해해야 해요.
임의의 벡터에 Dirac 표기법을 사용할 때
매우 중요한 규칙이 하나 있는데, 그건 열 벡터를
ket 프사이로 쓰기로 했다면,
또는 ket 안에 다른 이름이 있을 수 있는데, 행 벡터 bra 프사이는
벡터 ket 프사이의
켤레 전치로 이해돼요.
여기서 이건 등식으로 쓰여 있는데, 이 대거 기호가 켤레 전치를 가리켜요.
구체적으로 그게 뭔가 하면, 첫째로 벡터를 전치하는 거예요,
즉 벡터를 옆으로 뒤집어서 열에서 행으로 바꾸는 건데
항목은 실제로 변경하지 않고요. 그리고 둘째, 각 항목의
복소 켤레를 취해요.
이 두 연산, 전치와 항목별 복소 켤레를
어떤 순서로든 수행할 수 있어요, 이 두 연산은 교환 가능해요.
이 예시의 벡터에 대해, 이 벡터를
ket 프사이라고 부르기로 했으면, bra 프사이는 여기 이 벡터를 의미해요
벡터를 전치해서 ket 0과 ket 1을
bra 0과 bra 1으로 바꾸고, 각 항목의 복소 켤레를 취했어요,
그래서 (1 + 2i)/3이
여기서 (1 - 2i)/3으로 바뀐 거예요.
이 벡터들을 열 벡터와 행 벡터로
명시적으로 쓰면 이렇게 생겼어요.
참고로, 이 규칙은 bra와 ket 안에
고전 상태가 있을 때 사용하는 표기법과 일관돼요.
그 경우에는 항목이 하나의 1을 제외하고
모두 0이어서, 복소 켤레를 취해도 그 경우에는 아무것도 달라지지 않아요.
이제 양자 상태가 벡터로 어떻게 표현되는지 봤지만,
이 시점에서 의미나 함축이 뭔지는 명확하지 않아요
양자 상태에 있는 시스템으로
무엇을 할 수 있는지, 어떻게 상호작용할 수 있는지 측면에서요.
이 문제들을 명확히 하기 위해 첫 번째로 해야 할 일은
측정에 대해 논의하는 거예요.
직관적으로 말하면, 측정은 양자 시스템에서
고전 정보를 추출하는 메커니즘을 제공해요.
시스템이 양자 상태에 있을 때 보면,
확률적 상태가 보이지 않는 것처럼 양자 상태가 보이는 게 아니라,
고전 상태가 보이고, 이 측정이라는 개념이 그 인터페이스를 제공해요.
우리가 인간으로서 양자 시스템에 대해 뭔가를 알고 싶다면, 측정해야 하고, 그렇게 함으로써 그 시스템이 있던 양자 상태에 대한 고전 정보를 추출하게 돼요
그 시스템이 있던 어떤
양자 상태에 대해서요.
측정에 대한 다른 개념들이
있어요. 차이는 실제로 일반성의 문제인데, 가장 단순하고 기본적인 것부터 시작할 거예요,
그건 보통 표준 기저 측정이라고
불려요.
이후 레슨에서 이것을 일반화할 거예요.
레슨 3에서 소위 사영 측정에 대해 이야기하고, 그 후 시리즈의 세 번째 유닛에서
일반 측정에 대해 이야기할 건데, 이건
양의 연산자 값 측도, 줄여서 POVM이라고도 불려요.
하지만 지금은 표준 기저 측정으로 주의를 제한할 거예요.
시스템에 측정이 수행되면,
그 측정의 가능한 결과 집합이 있는데, 이것들은 고전적 결과예요,
표준 기저 측정의 경우, 가능한 결과는
측정되는 시스템의 고전 상태 그 자체예요.
각 고전 상태가 어떤 확률로 측정의 결과가 될 거고,
그 확률은
측정 직전 시스템이 있던 양자 상태 벡터에서
그 고전 상태에 해당하는 항목의 절대값 제곱이에요.
어떤 복소수의 절대값 제곱이 음이 아닌 실수라는 걸 알고, 양자 상태 벡터의 정의에서
양자 상태 벡터 항목의
절대값 제곱의 합이 1이라는 걸 알아요.
그래서 말이 돼요. 각 고전 상태가 어떤 확률로
측정의 결과로 나타날 거고, 확률의 합은 1이에요.
몇 가지 예시가 있어요. 먼저, qubit이
플러스 상태에 있다고 가정해 봐요.
이 qubit을 표준 기저 측정으로 측정하면,
결과로 0 또는 1을 얻어요.
0을 얻을 확률은 1/루트2의 절대값 제곱인
1/2이고, 1을 얻을 확률도 같아요.
그래서 플러스 상태를 측정하면 균일한 랜덤 비트를 얻어요.
시스템이 플러스 상태가 아니라
마이너스 상태에 있으면, 측정은 정확히 같은 방식으로 작동해요.
확률은 각 가능한 결과에 대해 역시 1/2예요.
여기서 유일한 차이는 플러스 부호가 마이너스 부호로 바뀌었다는 건데,
절대값을 취하면 아무것도 변하지 않아요.
이 qubit 상태를 측정하면, 결과 0을 얻을 확률은
(1 + 2i)/3의 절대값 제곱인 5/9이고,
결과 1을 얻을 확률은
-2/3의 절대값 제곱인 4/9예요.
마지막으로, 표준 기저 상태 ket 0을 측정하면
결과 0이 확실하게 나오고, 마찬가지로 상태 ket 1을 측정하면
결과 1이 확실하게 나와요. 왜냐하면
1의 절대값 제곱은 1이니까요.
확률적 설정에서와 비슷하게,
이 양자 상태 ket 0과 ket 1을 시스템이 그 고전 상태에 있는 것과 연관시킬 수 있고,
이 예시는 그 해석과
일치해요.
확률적 설정에서와 마찬가지로,
시스템이 양자 상태에 있을 때 측정하면,
측정을 수행한 결과로
일반적으로 상태가 변할 거예요.
특히, 확률적 설정에서와
정확히 같이요.
시스템을 측정하고 측정 결과가 고전 상태 a이면,
시스템의 새로운 양자 상태는 ket a가 돼요.
예를 들어 여기 이 상태에 대해서는
확률적 설정에서와 같은 종류의 행동을 볼 수 있어요.
측정하면 5/9의 확률로 결과 0을 얻고,
이 경우 상태는 ket 0으로 전이하고,
4/9의 확률로 결과가 1이고,
상태는 ket 1으로 전이해요.
때때로 이 현상을 양자 상태의 붕괴라고 부르는데,
이건 사람들을 밤새 깨어 있게 하는 종류의 것이에요
양자역학의 기초를
연구하는 사람들이요.
하지만 순수하게 수학적 관점에서는
정말 꽤 간단하고 확률적 경우에서와 매우 유사해요.
여기서 긴장의 원인은 어떤 의미에서 양자 상태의 근본적 성질과
그것이 무엇을 나타내는지, 그리고 어떻게 다른지에 관한 거예요
확률적 상태와요. 하지만 수학적 수준에서는, 이건 아마 여러분이 기대할 만한 거예요.
참고로, 두 번째로 측정하면,
첫 번째 측정과 정확히 같은 결과를 얻을 거예요.
그래서 양자 상태에서 추출할 수 있는 고전 정보의 양에 한계가 있고,
이 점에 대해 곧 다른 레슨에서 다시 돌아올 거예요
다른 레슨에서요. 양자 상태와 측정, 구체적으로는 표준 기저 측정에 대해 이야기했는데,
그건 양자 상태에서 고전 정보를
추출하는 방법을 제공해요.
이 레슨의 남은 주제는 연산,
구체적으로 유니터리 연산인데, 이건 시스템의 양자 상태가
어떻게 변할 수 있는지를 설명해요. 당연히,
양자 상태 벡터가 확률 벡터와 다르다는 점에서 허용되는 연산의 집합은
고전 정보에서와 다를 거라고 예상하시겠죠,
그리고 실제로 그래요.
확률적 상태에 대한 연산은 확률 행렬로 표현되는 반면,
양자 상태 벡터에 대한 연산은
유니터리 행렬로 표현돼요.
유니터리 행렬의 정의는 이거예요.
복소수 항목을 가진 정사각 행렬 U가
여기 보이는 등식을 만족하면 유니터리예요.
대거는 켤레 전치를 나타내는데,
잠시 전에 Dirac 표기법을 이야기할 때 벡터에 대해 이미 봤어요.
여기서는 벡터가 아니라 행렬에 대해
켤레 전치를 수행하는 건데, 본질적으로 같은 거예요.
행렬을 전치하면, 행과 열을 교환하는 거예요,
그래서 JK 항목이 KJ 항목이 되고,
또한 각 항목의
복소 켤레를 취해요.
그리고 여기 이 표기법은
단위 행렬을 의미해요.
여기 이 두 등식은 사실 동치예요.
하나가 있으면 자동으로 다른 하나도 있어요.
둘 다 U가 가역이고 역행렬이
켤레 전치와 같다고 말하는 것과 동치예요.
그건 정사각 행렬에 대해서만 참이에요, 참고로.
정사각이 아닌 행렬이면 두 등식 중 하나는 참일 수 있지만,
다른 하나는 참이 아닐 거예요.
하지만 여기서는
정사각 행렬에 대해 이야기하고 있어요.
이게 유니터리 행렬의 표준 정의이고,
행렬이 유니터리인지 확인하기 쉽기 때문에 좋아요.
행렬을 켤레 전치에 양쪽으로 곱해서
단위 행렬을 얻는지 보면 돼요.
유니터리 행렬을 특성화하는 동치적인 방법이 있는데,
정사각 행렬이 유니터리인 것은 곱할 때 어떤 벡터의 유클리드 노름도 절대 변경하지 않는 것과 동치예요
곱할 때요. N 곱하기 N 행렬 U가 유니터리인 것은
U 곱하기 v의 유클리드 노름이
복소수 항목을 가진 모든 n차원 열 벡터 v에 대해 v의 유클리드 노름과 같은 것과 동치예요.
따라서 v가 양자 상태 벡터이면,
U 곱하기 v도 양자 상태 벡터예요, 왜냐하면 양자 상태 벡터는
유클리드 노름이 1인
벡터일 뿐이니까요.
사실 좀 더 말할 수 있는데, 유니터리 행렬은 양자 상태 벡터를 항상
양자 상태 벡터로 변환하는 행렬 그 자체예요.
이건 확률 행렬과 확률 벡터에 대해
비슷한 상황이에요.
확률 행렬은 확률 벡터를 항상
확률 벡터로 변환하는 행렬 그 자체예요.
연산이 행렬로 표현되어야 한다고 결정했으면, 이건 변환이 상태를 나타내는 벡터에 선형으로 작용한다는 것과 같은 말인데,
허용 가능한 연산 집합에 대한 이러한 선택들은
적어도 수학적 의미에서 자연스럽게 따라와요.
이제 qubit 유니터리 연산의 몇 가지 예시를 살펴볼게요.
이후 레슨에서 유니터리 연산의 더 많은 예시를 보게 될 거예요,
두 개 이상의 고전 상태를 가진 시스템에 대한 유니터리 연산도 포함해서요
두 개 이상의 고전 상태를 가진 시스템이요.
하지만 지금은 qubit 유니터리 연산에만 집중할 거예요.
이 특정 예시들이 계속해서 다시 나올 거라서,
이 연산들을 잘 알아두는 게 확실히 가치 있어요.
첫 번째 예시 모음은 소위 Pauli 연산이에요.
이것들은 여기 보이는 Pauli 행렬에 대응하는 연산이에요.
모두 유니터리이고, 이전의 정의에 따라 각각에 대해 그걸 확인할 수 있어요.
이 특정 행렬들은 자신의 켤레 전치와
같다는 특성이 있는데, 즉 모두 에르미트 행렬이에요.
그래서 모두 유니터리인지 확인하는 것은,
이 경우 각각을 제곱해서 결과가 단위 행렬인지 확인하는 문제예요.
이 행렬들에 대해 보이는 이름은 꽤 표준적이고,
시그마 x, 시그마 y, 시그마 z를 그냥 X, Y, Z라고 부르는 것도 볼 수 있어요.
다만 대문자 X, Y, Z는 양자 정보의 맥락에서도
다른 용도로 흔하게 사용된다는 걸 알아두세요,
하지만 이 행렬들의 매우 흔한
이름이에요.
시그마 x 또는 X 연산은 비트 플립 또는
NOT 연산이라고도 불리는데, 고전적 맥락에서 이미 본 거예요.
그리고 시그마 z 또는 Z 연산은
위상 플립이라고도 불려요.
여기서 이 연산들이 표준 기저 벡터에
어떻게 작용하는지 볼 수 있는데, 이 이름들이 어디서 왔는지 설명해 줘요.
확실히 여기 이 작용을 보면
시그마 x를 비트 플립이라고 부르는 게 말이 돼요.
단순히 비트를 0에서 1로 또는
1에서 0으로 뒤집어요.
여기 이 작용을 보면 시그마 z를
위상 플립이라고 부르는 것도 말이 돼요.
하지만 지금 당장 완전히
명확하지 않아도 괜찮아요.
이 연산을 계속 마주치게 될 거고,
ket 1 기저 벡터 앞에 마이너스 부호를 넣고 ket 0에는 넣지 않는 것의 의미와
왜 그걸 위상 플립이라고 부르는지 나중에 더 명확해질 거예요.
다음 예시는 Hadamard 연산인데,
여기 이 행렬로 표현되고, 거의 항상 H라고 이름 붙여요.
H가 유니터리인지 확인하는 것은 역시
간단한 계산이고, 제가 비켜서면 여기서 볼 수 있어요.
Pauli 행렬과 비슷하게, H는 자신의 켤레 전치와 같아요.
그래서 여기 이 등식이 있고, 곱셈을 수행하면 필요한 대로 단위 행렬을 얻어요.
세 번째 예시는 사실 위상 연산이라고
알려진 유니터리 연산의 전체 클래스예요.
이것들은 여기 보이는 형태를 취하는 행렬로
표현되는 연산인데, 세타는 아무 실수나 돼요.
그래서 여기 이 항목은
항상 단위원 위의 어떤 복소수가 될 거예요.
이런 행렬은 항상 유니터리인데, 검증은 여러분에게 맡길게요.
이번에는 켤레 전치가 원래 행렬과 같지 않을 거예요, 이 수가
1이나 -1이 아닌 한요,
그 경우에는 단위 행렬이나
이미 만난 시그마 z가 돼요.
구체적으로, 전치는 이 행렬에 아무것도 하지 않지만,
각 항목의 복소 켤레를 취하면 여기 이 항목이 e의 -i세타 제곱으로 바뀌어요.
여기 이 두 특정 연산은 위상 연산의
특히 중요한 예시예요.
첫 번째는 세타를 파이/2로 잡으면
여기 이 행렬을 얻어요.
이건 보통 S 연산 또는 circuit에 대해 이야기할 때
S gate라고 부르는데, 이 레슨에서는 다루지 않을 거예요,
하지만 곧 나올 중요한
주제예요.
두 번째는 이 연산이에요. T 연산 또는 T gate예요.
이것에 대해서는 세타가 파이/4예요.
그래서 지수를 계산하면 여기 이 값을 얻는데, (1 + i)/루트2예요.
이 연산들 중 몇 가지가 작동하는 걸
보기 위한 간단한 예시가 몇 개 있어요.
ket 0과 ket 1에 대한
Hadamard 연산의 작용이 이거예요.
행렬-벡터 곱셈을 수행하면,
각각 플러스 상태와 마이너스 상태를 얻는 걸 볼 수 있어요.
반면에 플러스 상태와 마이너스 상태에
Hadamard 연산을 수행하면, ket 0과 ket 1로 돌아와요.
좀 정리하면, 작용을 더 명확하게 볼 수 있어요.
Hadamard 연산은 0 상태와 플러스 상태 사이,
그리고 1 상태와 마이너스 상태 사이를 왔다 갔다 변환해요.
여기 이 두 등식에 대해서, 이것이 플러스 상태와 마이너스 상태의 차이를 감지하는 간단한 방법을 제공한다는 걸 주목하세요.
레슨 앞부분에서 봤듯이, 플러스 상태와 마이너스 상태를
표준 기저 측정으로 측정하면,
두 경우 모두 균일한 랜덤 비트를 얻는데,
이건 차이를 감지하는 데 도움이 안 돼요.
하지만 Hadamard 연산을 수행하고 나서 측정하면,
원래 상태가 플러스 상태였으면 0을 보고
원래 상태가 마이너스 상태였으면
1을 볼 거예요.
그래서 이 두 상태는 실제로 다르고,
제가 방금 설명한 방법으로 완벽하게 구별할 수 있어요,
즉 먼저 Hadamard 연산을 수행하고
그다음 측정하는 거예요.
이전에 본 특별히 특별하지 않은 qubit 상태 예시로 돌아가면,
Hadamard 연산이 이 상태에 뭘 하는지
여기 보이는 형태로 변환하고
곱셈을 수행하면 볼 수 있어요.
그리고 여기 결과가 있는데,
원한다면 다시 Dirac 표기법으로 변환할 수 있고,
이런 종류의 작용을 계산하는
한 가지 방법이에요.
행렬 벡터 형태로 명시적으로 변환할 필요가
항상 있는 건 아니라는 걸 보여주는 또 다른 예시가 있어요.
Dirac 표기법을 직접 사용해서
이런 계산을 수행할 수도 있어요.
이 예시는 T 연산에 대한 건데,
참고로 여기 있어요.
이 연산은 표준 기저 상태에 대해 여기 이렇게 작용해요.
예를 들어 플러스 상태에 대한
T 연산의 작용을 계산하고 싶다면, 플러스 상태의 정의를 전개하는 것부터 시작하고
선형성을 사용해서
결과를 여기 보이는 것처럼 표현할 수 있어요.
이제 위에 있는 이 표현을 대입하고,
두 번째 항에 대해 약간의 단순화를 하면, 결과를 얻어요.
어떤 이유로 결과에 Hadamard 연산을
적용하고 싶다면, 비슷한 걸 할 수 있어요.
먼저 T가 플러스 상태에 작용하는 표현을 대입하고 이전처럼 선형성을 사용해요.
이제 ket 0과 ket 1에 대한 Hadamard 연산의
작용에 대해 이미 가진 표현을 대입하면,
이걸 얻어요. 이제 플러스 상태와 마이너스 상태를 전개하면
여기 이 표현을 얻고,
더하기만 해서 단순화할 수 있고, 여기 최종 결과가 있어요.
이 예시에 특별히 특별한 건 없어요.
이런 연산들의 작용을 계산하는 대안적이지만 동등한 방법을
보여주기 위한 거예요. 상황에 따라
더 편리한 방법을 사용하면 돼요.
유니터리 연산에 대한 마지막 포인트는
유니터리 연산의 합성이 행렬 곱셈으로 표현된다는 거예요
확률적 설정에서처럼요, 즉 유니터리 연산 시퀀스의
작용은
단순히 행렬들을 함께 곱해서
계산할 수 있어요. 그리고 얻는 건 결합된 작용을 나타내는 하나의 유니터리 행렬이에요
연산 시퀀스의요.
확률 행렬에서와 마찬가지로, 유니터리 행렬은
곱셈에 대해 닫혀 있어요, 그래서 유니터리 연산을 합성하면 항상 유니터리 행렬을 얻어요
유니터리 연산을 합성할 때요.
행렬을 올바른 순서로
곱해야 해요.
하지만 작동 방식은 확률적 연산에서와
같아서, 먼저 수행하는 연산의 행렬이
항상 행렬 곱의 오른쪽에 나타나고,
마지막 것이 왼쪽에 나타나요.
이전과 마찬가지로, 왼쪽에서 오른쪽이 아니라 오른쪽에서 왼쪽으로 합성한다는 의미에서 순서가 뒤집혀요.
NOT의 제곱근 연산이라고 알려진 연산을 만드는 흥미로운 예시가 있어요.
먼저 Hadamard 연산을 적용하고,
그다음 S 연산, 그다음 또 다른 Hadamard 연산을 적용한다고 가정해요.
이 세 연산의 결합된 작용은
이 곱으로 설명돼요.
여기 첫 번째 Hadamard 연산이고, 여기 S 연산이고, 여기 두 번째 Hadamard 연산이에요.
행렬 곱셈을 수행하면, 여기서 명시적으로 보여주지는 않지만
원하시면 직접 할 수 있어요,
결과는 여기 이 행렬이에요. 유니터리 행렬이고, 직접 확인할 수도 있고
유니터리 행렬이 곱셈에 대해 닫혀 있다는
사실을 믿을 수도 있어요.
이미 봤듯이 이 세 행렬이 유니터리이기 때문에 반드시 유니터리여야 해요.
여기서 특정 양자 상태 벡터를
염두에 두고 있는 건 아니에요.
어떤 양자 상태 벡터에든 이 연산 시퀀스를
수행하는 걸 상상할 수 있고, 이 행렬이 그 작용을 설명해요.
이 결합된 연산, 즉 여기 이 행렬로 설명되는 연산이
NOT의 제곱근 연산이라고 불리는 이유는,
두 번 수행하면 NOT 연산을 얻기 때문이에요,
다시 말해 시그마 x 또는 X 연산이요.
연산을 두 번 수행하는 것은
행렬을 제곱하거나 자기 자신에 곱하는 것으로 표현돼요.
그리고 이렇게 하면, 결과가
Pauli x 행렬인 걸 볼 수 있어요.
그건 좀 특이한데, 고전 정보로는 할 수 없는
양자 정보로 흥미로운 것들을 할 수 있다는 힌트를 줘요.
두 번 수행하면 NOT 연산을 주는
고전적 연산, 즉 확률 행렬로 표현되는 연산은 없어요.
양자 연산이 고전 연산과 매우 다르게 동작한다는 걸
보여주는 좋은 예시예요.
레슨 1은 여기까지예요. 이 레슨에서는 단일 시스템의 독립적인 경우에 양자 정보가 어떻게 작동하는지 논의했고,
다음 레슨에서는 여러 시스템에 대해
양자 정보가 어떻게 작동하는지 이야기할 거예요.
시청해 주셔서 감사해요. 질문이 있으시면 아래 댓글란에
남겨 주세요.